would you say screenwriting is hard
because I'm sure a lot of people could
look at your story they could look at
your credits and you make it look easy
in terms of wow that's a really cool
story here you were 14 and you send this
you know script idea off and although
it's rejected and you don't know what
the notes are you still have this
relationship that really shaped you in a
lot of ways and I think it's a really
cool story and not a lot of people
probably have that opportunity but it is
it hard because it looks easy yeah from
the outsiders yeah it's it's it's hard
it's it's always interesting because if
sometimes if I if I have a story that I
love and I've outlined it then it's just
fun but when you're again when you're
definitely trying to do a lot of things
and get a lot of things like because
then you know you know I'm at the point
in my career now where I want to you
know just branch out and tell you know
still horror stories but like do
something like the Lionsgate project
which is you know I think gonna it's
just a really important kind of thing
that you've you know where you had to
fight for it it is hard because you want
to you you want to write something
that's gonna strike a chord to people
but you want to write something that's
successful you want to write something
that's going to spawn a franchise and
and I've had you know for better for
worse for some of my films they've done
really well and other ones that we're
supposed to turn out well didn't quite
turn out that we're supposed to and what
you know directive video or didn't get a
good release and you know there's so
there's again there's it's you
definitely have to stay in gratitude a
lot of times and you have to find the
joy in it all you know in the joy in
writing and I still love writing
especially when I'm you know through if
I'm writing something else and I get
something this inspires me to like you
know I guess I hate to say it kills
thing but you know I could kill I'm like
oh my god I've never liked I just
thought of a great scene for a movie
that you know I was so excited and I
called the producer about and he's like
was in love with it and so that's a fun
stuff you know I was like trying to come
up with new new things but you know it
is hard to sit down in front of the
computer every day and you know writing
a hundred page script you know that's it
is it is work and it's and it's not it's
not easy you know because you're you're
trying to write something that is going
to be creatively satisfying
your turn write something that you think
will sell because this is your
livelihood so you're trying to juggle
both of those things but not get too far
down the road that you're not focused on
the finishing the actual script you know
so you've got to keep all those other
things out of your or try to keep them
out of your head about is this gonna
sell is this gonna make money or people
gonna like this yeah they try not to
like focus too much on that and just get
the script done but that can be hard in
and of itself you know it's not future
tripping about you know what's gonna
happen with the script once you're done
with it so it's um it's fun but it's not
easy it's not easy and there are harder
you know it's always it's like with
actors you know when because acting is
not easy to be a good actor is not easy
but you know you know it's not like
we're going into you know putting out
fires and you know putting our lives in
danger and you know doing like
physically hard labor it's just mental
it's just mental exhaustion you know
it's a lot a lot of mental work did this
screenwriting career that you envisioned
look the same in terms of the day-to-day
because you know how people have a
romantic notion about what something is
I see you know no not at all yeah yeah
because you don't you don't really
envision with the writing like I you
don't realize how long it takes to write
a script first of all and then you know
like I you know I had a friend once who
was like oh yeah I just took a took a
weekend trip to Hawaii and wrote my
script on the beach with some mai tais
I'm like oh that's what writing is you
just call for a weekend and you write a
script and ya know the day-to-day grind
of getting you know two or three or four
or five pages a day done is like it's a
it's a grind and then you've also got
life that you're living and you also
have to try to get out and have a life
because if you don't have a life you
know like I'm kind of joking because we
are you know writers are some very
solitary but you know I do go out to the
movies and I do go out to dinner I do go
out and do some of my friends cuz
otherwise if you sit at home all the
time you're not experienced in life and
so then you can't bring anything else to
your scripts than what you've already
experienced so you just kind of
regurgitating the same experiences that
you've had so you've got to kind of make
sure your cup is like flowing over with
other things besides just work but you
have to take time out to do that too so
in terms of what most people wouldn't
like you know you're at the keyboard and
you've got it well not a drink but you
know some people in you know they think
that that's part of with the cigarette
and just like this torture existence oh
yeah and you're pounding out and then
this thing is beautiful in it but it
sounds like it's it's there's more of a
science to it and it's not just there's
a science but for some people again
everybody has a different method which
is is very interesting it's like it's
like with acting like you have your
method actors who have to be like you
know they have to become the character
and they have to you you have your other
actors who when a camera when the
director says you know rolling you know
then they just they they go and then cut
then they draw it back and who they are
and I think they're writers that are the
same way to like you know yeah there's a
stereotype that's why I quit drinking
it's like I was becoming that Sarah
Tobias something here drinking at home
and you know thinking I'm writing some
brilliant stuff and yeah the first
couple pages were great and then the
rest of it's like what the hell was I
writing so you know you think you do
think that that's kind of I do have some
friends that do torture themselves
without the drinking or anything they
just you know it's like they obsess
about every single line of dialogue and
it's like you're never gonna finish your
script if you're like that but again
that's how they are so everybody's got a
whole different process and so that's
why I always tell people don't don't
judge yourself harshly if your process
isn't the same as somebody else's you
know because it really is your end
result that matters it's like getting
that script finished so you do obviously
have to follow certain you know
structural rules and certain you know
your dialogue needs to be good you're
you know it has to be an engaging story
but sometimes it takes people a lot
longer you know I've known friends that
where it's taken them 10 years to write
a script you know it's not like they're
working every day eight hours a day on
it but you know 10 years yeah yeah I had
a couple friends at have like yeah I've
been working on this for 10 years and
and it's great some of this stuff's
great and I've read some scripts where
people have written script in a week and
it's great not consistently but you know
but it's everybody's got a different
thing and I think that's what's always
interesting too is we always have our
ideas in our head what everybody's life
is like and it's like you know even what
you think an actor's life is like like
it their lives you know the celebrities
lives I mean they're you know they are
like trudging into Starbucks with their
dog and their kids crying and have to go
change your kid's diaper and you know
just like everybody else is you know
like you know so you you definitely the
glamour of Hollywood that they used to
project and was so important back in the
days of you know the olden days with the
with the Hollywood stars you know which
when it was like the stars ran
everything and they had to keep up these
perfect images like we've lost all that
now with like the internet and access to
everybody's private lives and you know
we see people now on the street you know
people are taking pictures of people and
it's like oh wait I mean they're just
like a you know like that's even a I
think people are something has a whole
thing like celebrities they're just like
us and it shows pictures of them like
walking a dog and before that you
thought these are there were these
magical creatures and you know you
thought these writers were these like
tortured you know sitting in a dark room
like with you know just pounding away at
the keyboard and you know sipping from
their bottle of whiskey and you know
curse in the heavens and yeah it's it's
it's different for everybody assume for
everybody but they're all at Starbucks I
mean they definitely have coffee shops
are full of Striders in California
that's definitely a cliche that you
can't
that's one cliche that's true it's like
you go every coffee shop there's
somebody's work there's five people
working on the screenplay at any coffee
shop that you walk into so it's pretty
funny
you